[Music]
tiny tea i don't feel like you put a lot
of effort into this
you didn't give me anything that was
super memorable or super special and
you're too special of a kid to do that
jess
i'm sorry can i say something of course
honestly tiny was not busy with
something else we really really work on
a song at night and whole day until
coming here she said i want to show
jason jojo that she can do
this way also
i understand that and i understand that
the calm is special for you
out of the box for you but for me it was
too simple
please welcome the one the only miss
jojo seaworld
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
all of you and you're the closest people
to me and you know i don't cry
you all know that hold on i gotta pull
myself together really quick
thank you all for coming first of all i
really really really appreciate it
being who i am and doing what i do
i have met
countless amount of kids that are sick
no one wants to see anyone go through
childhood cancer
it breaks my heart to see
what i want to do with this foundation
is
i want to make
kids life better and my priority is
donating to kids
making sure they have a great life
and that is why i created jojo siwa's
childhood cancer foundation
there's nothing worse in the world than
watching someone that you love suffer
jojo's giving families
beautiful moments
and
that's important for their family
together
so that's a beautiful thing that we're
really happy to be a part of
leah what happened last night i guess
maybe i was just thrown off but i'm here
today i'm ready
honestly that happens sometimes and we
move dancers around and one minute you
might be the lead talking to jojo and
the next minute you might be stuck in a
unicorn costume you know so that that's
a huge part of life and i appreciate
that you let it be what was best for the
group
everything you've done
has been with hard work
and perseverance
and dedication
i
know you're the fan favorite
and i want to tell you that
you're the next permanent member
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god it doesn't feel real like
i have the jacket on and i'm the third
member of the group like
omg
i tell emg
dallas
i think tonight you were an angel on
stage
as hard as it is to bring the house down
with a ballad you did
and you did it your way
and i hope tonight
when you go to bed
you sleep in your exo mv jacket
[Music]
it's my dream come true
[Music]
you